[Música]
vamos al repaso de las noticias
económicas con Daniela hablandono
Daniela saludo para usted Nuevamente
muchas gracias Ángela vamos a Washington
se reúnen diariamente para intentar
solucionar estas discusiones en torno al
techo de la deuda en que va la cosa pues
Ángela Está avanzando este conteo
regresivo queda poco más de una semana
para que demócratas y republicanos
puedan cerrar esta brecha Que los separa
en cuanto a los niveles de gasto del
país de lo contrario podrían entrar en
un incumplimiento a partir del primero
de junio como ya lo ha dicho
reiteradamente el departamento del
tesoro pues tanto el líder republicano
Kevin mccarthy como el presidente biden
ordenaron a sus negociadores que
trabajaran toda la noche del lunes en
este asunto y así sucesivamente todos
los días hasta que lleguen a un acuerdo
mire ante esta cuenta regresiva de los
nueve días Sería muy bueno hacer el
repaso y usted lo ha hecho muy bien
sobre qué tan separadas están las
posiciones entre republicanos y
demócratas entonces lo que más los
divide es Cómo controlar el déficit
Federal que para los próximos años se
reducirían 4,8 billones de dólares según
los republicanos una cifra mucho menor a
la que vemos acá de los demócratas de
2,8 billones de dólares en esos mismos
10 años el gobierno va a ir en argumenta
que los estadounidenses ricos y las
empresas son Quienes deberían pagar más
impuestos pero los republicanos en lugar
de tocar esos gravamenes lo que quieren
es recortar gastos a niveles de 2022
biden también quiere reducir el déficit
cerrando las lagunas Fiscales de las
Industrias petrolera y farmacéutica Pero
macar ha declarado que aumentar los
ingresos no es una opción que todo tiene
que venir por el lado del gasto y que
por ejemplo si se deberían eliminar las
subvenciones Fiscales a la energía
limpia aprobadas en la ley de reducción
de inflación o también revocar la
condonación de deudas estudiantiles este
último tema que está Atrapado en
tribunales bien vamos a ir a América
Latina porque Argentina sigue tomando
medidas económicas con la intención de
tratar de frenar la inflación y sobre
todo la fuga de las Divisas Pues por un
lado anunció un acuerdo con las
entidades bancarias públicas y privadas
de capital nacional para aumentar hasta
en un 30% el cupo de compra con tarjetas
de crédito de acuerdo con estas nuevas
disposiciones alrededor de 39 millones
de argentinos podrán aumentar su cupo
esto lo explican los medios locales de
la siguiente manera si una familia
contaba con 50 mil pesos de crédito en
su tarjeta ahora va a tener 65 mil pesos
también hubo otro anuncio y fue la
apuesta en circulación de un billete de
2000 pesos de mayor denominación que
tiene un valor de solamente cuatro
dólares según los tipos de cambio
paralelos que son los más utilizados en
este país y a la tasa oficial serían
unos 8,50 dólares y para algunos esto
podrían ser pañitos de agua tibia no
Claro porque están exigiendo
denominaciones inclusive más altas para
poder absorber toda esta inflación del
109% anual que ya tienen Pues bien
Daniela vamos a cambiar de tema vamos a
la Unión Europea con una noticia que
ojalá Ojalá funcione y es una norma para
ponerle freno al desperdicio de prendas
de vestir Pues los 27 los representantes
de los 27 miembros del bloque
comunitario acordaron prohibir la
destrucción de textiles no vendidos como
parte del impulso verde que se quiere
dar para reducir los desechos a través
de una mayor reutilización y también del
reciclaje algo muy significativo si se
tiene en cuenta que el consumo de
textiles en Europa tiene el cuarto mayor
impacto sobre el medio ambiente después
de la Alimentación la vivienda y la
movilidad y que cada año se desechan
alrededor de 5,8 millones de toneladas
de textiles en estos países esto
equivale Aproximadamente a 11 kg por
persona gran parte de los cuales
terminan depositados en vertederos o se
incinerana
la decisión de hoy es un paso importante
hacia la economía circular verde además
de fortalecer el mercado único el
reglamento promoverá la economía
circular en la Unión Europea al crear un
marco para que la comisión establezca
requisitos para los productos en
términos ambientales y de disponibilidad
ahora tenemos esta posición antes de las
negociaciones con el parlamento europeo
que comenzarán pronto
y Daniela no puedo darle la despedida
sin antes recibir de usted Los
indicadores de la jornada clave sobre
todo en estas fechas tan importantes
para la bolsa en Wall Street está
rondando ese fantasma del default Y eso
tiene a la bolsa en rojo a pesar de que
sus movimientos son bastante tímidos
hasta tanto se alcance un acuerdo o se
rompan las negociaciones en Europa hay
caídas pero se destaca el alza en la
bolsa de Londres después de que el fondo
monetario internacional dijera que este
año podría esquivar la recesión que era
inicialmente prevista también hay
noticias de Mercado el gigante
energético ruso gasproma en reveló que
sus utilidades netas se desplomaron en
más del 41% durante 2022 y aunque lo
atribuyó principalmente a un aumento de
impuestos sus exportaciones se redujeron
casi a la mitad tras las sanciones
impuestas por la invasión a Ucrania sus
acciones están cayendo un 4% en este
momento en la bolsa de Moscú por otro
lado el ministro de energía de Qatar
anticipó que la transición energética es
No alcanzable y que habrá una gran
escasez de gas en el futuro todo esto
debido a los agresivos esfuerzos que se
están haciendo en todo el mundo al
respecto lo que dicen ellos es que sí
hay que hacer transición pero que no
puede ser tan rápido como lo están
haciendo pues así está la cosa Daniela
no seguimos conversando mañana mañana
nos vemos acá pues muchas gracias